[Musik]
sind die einsam
ich finde mich wieso will ein mensch
nichts mehr mit menschen zu tun haben
darum geht es in dieser geschichte
es muss es überlässt
jetzt schon wieder durchstarten
das ist technik die modernisiert u-bahn-
1600 quadratmeter großer report mit
einem kleinen wäldchen im zürcher
unterland gelegen
das ist seit über vier jahren das
zuhause des karlsruher liman gefährlich
bald wird werde ich meine hier bin hat
er sich zurückgezogen um den riedberg zu
unterhalten und war dann nur noch in
guter gesellschaft zu sein also ganz für
sich fanden wir da wir die erklärung
wird abstieg 120 stunden gezahlt
im jahr und das heißt und sie sehr
verschieden ganze reihe und der machen
gern immer verrückter freitag und
abbildung sogenannte die erbrachten
gewinnmitnahmen und behaupten und der
würfe zurück
ich erschrak so modul anschluss gleich
dicke da wieder so wunderbar waren dass
ich danke ich so was sie nun mal nicht
machen solarheizung wie oft sie dann da
wir wie oft du steht sie da eigentlich
wieder hoch
das lange macht haben
doch wissen sie ja bereits in österreich
oder morgens of the boards mit
mindestens unter hygienisch behandelt
bevor der charaktere aus schweizer krank
sind robust
der generierte gesellschaftliche
komplett an suleman sicht werden wir
immer schwächlicher immer dümmer kurzum
immer degenerierter das drücke sich vor
allem im raubbau an der natur aus höher
man will sich diesen wahnsinn nicht mehr
aus der nähe ansehen
mittlerweile ist der 78 und die ihm
verbleibende lebenszeit seien schlicht
zu wertvoll sind geduldige menschen
geduldig ja da war vergab der vor der
rapper gehört einer art gemeinschaft
bestehen dass hürlimann und seinen
geschwistern dass es sich hier auf der
flucht vor der fortschreitenden
verdummung der menschheit häuslich
eingerichtet hat finden alle originell
sagt er
bislang machen wie lange geplant gewesen
lustig lustig finde es gut dass ich so
extrem noch übrig extremisten und und
sind dann also das könnte ich mir was
acht stunden dass diese studie nehmen
weniger begeistert ist freilich die
gemeinde mit der hülle man seit einigen
jahren eine dauerfehde ausficht sind wie
im winter mit ja und dann haben ist
wunderschön aber ein schönes los
denn zieht aus und boten dabei überhaupt
keine hilfe die ich hoffe dass ich das
mammut zuschlag
ich bin dabei waren der fall ist falsch
als richtig weil ich sie können sie dann
doch mal ist bei uns so cool dass ich
eben ja auch hier tritt im sommer und
zwar nicht was man kann sich den schlaf
waren sich ans becken jo klimapolitik
bei den freeride mache ich auch
geschäftskritische in italy alaba und da
sehen tiefer gute gesunde schlaf haben
partie und den trophy bei dem schöpfer
auch vor gut zwei jahren für den schönen
tag dankte ist indes fraglich
bis vor bundesgericht hatte julian
prozessiert und verloren
eine notdürftige bleibe war für illegal
erklärt worden er hatte gegen paragrafen
in einer schutz verordnung verstoßen
die gemeinde steht zugleich zur tat und
listen gesetzwidrigen bauten abreißen
[Musik]
jeder weiß die verdauung zu verdauen
fast jeder alles denn die eine
quadratmeter land alles was er braucht
das ist liebe das filmbild juli-chef ja
das sind genial anfang juli mann ist
geblieben
denn er hat inzwischen eine
gesetzeslücke gefunden wenn er lediglich
brauchen spart dann campiert er im
juristischen sinne und campieren ist in
besagter schutzverordnung nicht explizit
verboten also können die behörden ihm
nichts mehr anhaben
vorsichtig starken abgaben ist ein
heller kopf
er war jahrzehnte lang inspektor für
gasturbinen für die bbc
die spätere abb in dieser funktion reist
er um die welt und verdiente nach
eigenen angaben monatlich 25000 franken
die sich auf seinen bank konnte im laufe
der jahre zu millionen agiert hätten
was machen sie einen mit all ihrem geld
wenn sie das spare aston villa das
mittel und vielleicht waschmittel was
immer kommunen nicht
und mit pensionen darf auch nicht so
viele wohltätige zwecke spenden
ja ich trage dich
juli mann war zeitlebens ein
einzelgänger
gut dass einmal verheiratet gewesen sagt
er beiläufig und gut habe man drei
kinder gezeugt aber das sei lange her
sehr lange verdienen habe heute zum
glück ruhe
er müsste nur noch einmal pro woche
unter die leute für seinen einkauf hat
seit ich es bestimmt sehr eigenes gewo
sie dazu gebracht hat sich zurückziehe
vor der masche war es dann wenn ich also
familie wie die mit drei kollegen sind
gleich null ist immer leichter machen
druck und ausnahmen gibt es nicht
und das mag ich nicht vermutet dass das
macht mich dass ich das gar nicht ob sie
ihr kind lernen die kinder in der
nachbarschaft die eltern erzieherisch
abwesend verlieh man das finale indiz
für die fortschreitende der generierung
der menschheit und ein verlauf ist einen
exodus sind die einsiedelei er selber
habe seine drei kinder noch mit harter
hand erzogen wobei es natürlich noch
besser gewesen wäre ihnen das leben gar
nicht zuzumuten und des hans carossa
shorts gewissen einfluss da wird sich
aber hin wonach hinterwagen beklagte
mädels machen
ja also 105 glauben
wer so geht das noch mal wirklich
ja klar aber ich brauche zwei hunde soja
sie ernähren sich cool ich habe mich aus
leichte komme es durch die aber nicht
buchen typ den man gern haben den zenit
hinaus regina halmich beraten
pro person 800 frauen körper braucht
will us-bürger wurde das ausstrecken
aber salz kann
es ist ein beklemmendes oszillieren
zwischen der freude an irdischen
genüssen und dem ekel vor der welt an
der fischtheke natürlich man wunderbare
meeresfrüchte gesehen aber gleichzeitig
auch eisgekühlte vorboten des untergangs
ich es ja immer gern fisch vor 56 jahren
bis dann hat man die füße stellen und
die 100 jahre als radioaktiv hoffnung
ist in höhe manns welt ein indiz für
realitätsverweigerung zukunfts glaube
etwas für genau wer er war
denn ich hätte ein doppeltes besser
machte kaum vorstellbar dieser mann
hatte vor 40 jahren tatsächlich
schmetterlinge im bauch und will
glücklich gewesen sein
mit einer frau namens elizabeth nach
name unbekannt von beruf physiotherapeut
in anfangs war es ist eine geliebte
später in der zeit nach seiner familie
seine partnerin bis heute seit über 20
jahren führen sie eine fernbeziehung sie
lebt er hier
man hat ihnen eine flashmob seite hat
die gmbh ist mit als ob die jesus
glauben teilen der welt geschickt
und sie
ich hoffe dir hier ist sie dort also wo
da ja ja ich chef thomas sieber gebäude
jeder schaue mir sagen sie gelegt oder
so was eben bei den leuten gut aber ich
danke sagen muss es nicht unbedingt
sagen sie merkte dass man das nicht
verhindert wurde
dass sie nun seine partnerin geblieben
ist störe ihn nicht im gegenteil
es komme seinem naturell entgegen mit
ihr telefoniert er ab und zu und zieht
sich höchstens einmal pro monat
das reiche ihm völlig die physischen
bedürfnisse nehmen im alter sowieso auf
sagt er
der wunsch nach stille wachsen indes
fast fällt ihre partnerin eigentlich
ihnen traten im fernsehen
sie stehen dort weder als ich glaube
aachen studiert und verglichen was ich
so kurz ist ja das kabinett nach dass
sie ja klar
udine das weh wenn ihre partnerin mit
ihnen öffentliche verbindung gebracht
werden braucht es ist gut dass sie tag
fällig da liegt ich sagen spät
ich will damit oder später haben was
jahres merkel ich bin gut was dann kommt
sie wieder anziehen
hallo ich habe
es ist schön weil sie kontert eine
schöne warme wohnung jedoch war ich habe
haben da hab ich nix zu holen kann man
schnell und ruhig kann man schlecht -
das ist die gewählte unverständlich dass
ich zähle mich kabasi unicum benötigten
nicht ob ich bin heute manche sind eben
menschen was eine duldung
[Musik]
wann sie aufwerten möchte sie werden ja
wirklich schon immer war schon immer so
außerdem möglich ich bewahre mir einige
sachen leistbar sagt aber auch ich
brauche es nötig für mich aber sollen
gleichwohl studiert hürlimann diese
orientalischen märchen fast schon
obsessiv tag für tag liest er in der
bibel als ob ihm der gedanke zunehmend
unheimlich würde das das leben wirklich
absurd sein könnte dass der mensch auf
einem trudelten himmelskörper gestrandet
ist verloren
in unendlichen kosmischen weiten und in
sinnlosigkeit
standard für sie eine option
dass wir das nicht machen da ist ja
normal
also was ich kann
aber sie glauben dass sie in sieht man
müsste sie ja keine konsequenzen
gewärtigen
sie hebe das war eine genau wann sind
sie auf der sicheren seite
im zweifelsfall ja
man hat sie alles lag schon operiert das
kann ja auch nicht einen graben das ist
für mich als kind und als gitarrist der
welt ich sehe mich als hätte ich die
gallier sind sie kann sensible mensch
ich finde das abwandern von gewalt ein
selbstschutz dass das keine stimme
[Musik]